- [Amber] Hey Buzzfeed,
it's your girl Amber,
aka @jstlbby and here's
a little bit about me.
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] Amber Wagner,
aka @jstlbby, gained fame
with her witty inspirational videos.
(upbeat music)
- I've noticed that you've kind of been
hard on yourself, you feel me?
Right now, I want you to take a minute
and thank your damn self.
Hug yourself if you can, you feel me?
Pat your damn self on the back.
I grew up in a two-parent home
with my mother and father.
In Englewood, California.
I'm very ghetto, loud,
always playing double-dutch
walking to the corner
store, eatin' too much.
You know, kid stuff.
I always had an outgoing,
bubbly personality.
I'm always loud, always
rambunctious, clumsy as hell.
Just me, wild.
I got on Instagram in 2014 and uh, I just
started there with just regular pictures.
Then one day, I had um, did a video
about my ex.
Hey 'ista, my ex tried
to get back with me,
you know what I said?
Hell no, bitch! (laughs)
And that went viral.
Then I did a video off of
Beyonce's song Drunk in Love.
So, every since I heard Beyonce sing
♪ I've been drinking watermelon ♪
Bitch, me too! The fuck!
The first time I realized
that this could be something
big was when the Shade Room
had posted me on their page.
After that, celebrities
started posting me,
they started following me and I was like,
okay, this is serious now.
What made me want to be
motivational was just my life,
I was in a dark place
for awhile, you know,
dealing with these guys
usin' and abusin' me
and then me just not
really fully lovin' myself
and knowin' who I was.
And once I did, I don't know,
a sense just came over me
like you know what, you
need to put this out there.
My mother is like my biggest
inspiration, motivator
and everything because that
woman is just so strong.
Like, she has been through
so much from hip surgery,
shoulder surgery, everything.
Still helping my grandfather
who was bed-ridden.
Brushing his teeth, making his meals.
And she still remains
positive, still remains happy.
Still just does her best.
At first when I started
social media, she told me
"you're not funny, nobody's
going to like you".
I'm like, okay.
And I was crying, I was so sad.
Next thing you know, I showed
her I was in the Shade Room
and I showed her where
Rihanna was following me
and other people, then
she made a Instagram.
Now she loves it. She wears
my T-shirt out in public.
People say, "oh my god, you know her?"
She's like, "Yes, that's my daughter."
Okay, so, when I'm in my zone,
getting ready to do my videos
I'm usually at my desk, okay.
I have my phone here and I
have to get my mind right.
So, I think of a topic.
For instance, heartbreak.
So, in my head, niggas I
ain't shared, okay, nuh-uh
they doggin' us out, whatever.
So I'm like, okay, let me get ready.
I usually, you know, you know me.
Put my glasses on, I'm in my zone, so.
Hey, Valentine's Day is tomorrow.
I'm single, and I ain't
even trippin'. It's okay.
I just speak, like, you
know, about who I am
and situations that I've been through.
And you know, with me
being like, plus size,
I want to help the plus size young ladies.
And people ask me how do I do it?
I say, I just, honestly
what I did, I just pray
about it and I just keep
going. Everything is pure.
It's nothin' forced.
The message I would like to
send to younger females of color
is embrace yourself, don't base how other
people feel about you,
how you feel about yourself.
Don't let anybody
deteriorate you, deter you
from what you're doing.
Just keep being you.
You are the mother-fucking shit.
You are great.
- You're actually a queen.
You inspire me so much.
You really are. I'm so sorry.
- No, I appreciate your positivity.
Thank you.
Give me another hug, that just made my day
- Oh my god.
(Upbeat music)